response to the pandemic the clark
county school district is giving
eligible full-time employees a retention
bonus ccs ccsd trustees made the move
official during their regular board
meeting this week mary jane belliesa
shares how teachers are responding
this month the clark county school
district will pay full-time employees a
bonus of a thousand dollars and starting
in may ccsd will pay an additional one
thousand dollar bonus to full-time
employees vicki kreidel a second grade
teacher and president of the national
education alliance of southern nevada
says this money will help cover the
rising costs of bills during this
pandemic we've had an increase in
not just cost of living like rent and
everything is going up in vegas
but
our health costs have gone up
exponentially since october 1st
and
so
yeah that many will probably for most of
us be used in trying to cover some of
the additional expenses that we have
noelle clement is a teacher serving
students out in indian springs and is
part of the clark county education
association board she hopes the
eligibility guidelines doesn't exclude
staff who work the same amount of hours
but hold different positions and a lot
of it winds up being support positions
like our bus drivers and are in class
so these are also you know adult folks
that have specific skill sets and
they're working with kids and they may
not be getting the same
you know monetary support as full-time
teachers that are in the classroom ccsd
has allocated approximately 80 million
in elementary and secondary school
emergency relief funds to cover the
expected cost of the retention bonuses
mary jane balliesa live local now